I'm joined by Labor's Shadow leveling up
secretary Lisa Mandy
um but firstly so I'd like to talk to
you about your reaction to that news
from channel 4 not being sold and to
remain publicly owned can you tell us
what you make of that decision well it's
the right decision and it's an enormous
relief that the government has dropped
these crazy plans to try and flog
Channel 4 off to the highest bidder
Channel 4 is one of the crown jewels in
terms of having a presence in all of our
Nations and regions in terms of
supporting the independent production
sector in this country and making sure
that every part of this country is
reflected in our national story it would
have been a huge Act of economic
vandalism to sell it off to the highest
bidder and it's a relief that the
government has finally seen sense and
back down
right so let's then move to
um uh Kia stormer's speech just now uh
just a short while ago in the last hour
we ran that live here on Sky News I was
listening in he's clearly trying to
pitch himself as a man of the people he
talked about understanding and
empathizing with the shame of not
knowing what it's like to pay bills
clearly pitching himself as the complete
opposite of of Rishi sunak who who is a
multi-millionaire trying to appeal to
everybody but can he really appeal to
everybody in Britain I think so because
he respects the contribution that people
have to make and that's the key message
from this speech today that if this
country is going to work our way out of
this crisis that we're in where nothing
is working where everything is broken
after 10 years of Decay and decline then
it's going to take a nation and that's
why the First Act of the new labor
government will be to introduce an act
of Parliament pushes power out of
Westminster and Whitehall that enables
local communities to take control of
their own destiny to drive growth to
start to rebuild our Public Services the
tourists think you can grow the economy
by the few for the few we say it takes a
nation and that's what we're setting out
today
okay so let's talk about the
nitty-gritties and the details because
kirstama was critical of the Tories for
providing common free without solution
um Rachel Reeves told us on Sky News on
breakfast this morning that every policy
you've come up with has been costed and
funded clearly clearly trying to deflect
previous criticisms but we didn't really
hear much of what secure plans to do you
mentioned one uh reform law there you
know there was no who what when why how
well just to give you an example we
believe that this country could do far
better if we move to cheaper renewable
energy and ended our dependence on
energy from Russia and from other
authoritarian countries we think that
that will create good jobs in every part
of Britain and we're setting out a
long-term plan to do it no more sticking
plasters no more lurching from one
short-term solution to a food crisis to
another that's the approach that the
next Labor government is going to take
and everything that we promise we will
cost and we'll know that we can deliver
because that's what the British people
expect and that's what they deserve
okay so do you think though that the
party can hold on to the next election
really because you know the polls are
tricky and it's tough sometimes to keep
an electorate so convinced and to keep
such highs
look it's it's up to the British people
we would never be as presumptuous to
believe that the next election is a
foregone conclusion for anybody but I
think wherever you go in this country
people can see that this country needs a
plan nothing is working the government
hasn't got a grip whether you walk into
your local a e or you walk down your
local High Street you can see that
things are falling apart but we know
that they can be different we know that
because across this country and every
Community there are local leaders there
are business people there are
communities who are coming together to
build and the next Labor government is
going to hand them tools to do that
whether it's Powers over skills
transport job centers housing these are
the things that enable places to thrive
and enable this country to succeed again
and we're going to hand those tools back
to communities as a partnership between
government and the people so that we can
build the country that we know that we
can be
I was interested to hear sakir talking
about taking back control the fact that
when he was uh talking to people around
the country about remaining uh on the
leave vote on the brexit vote that there
was a lot that he couldn't argue against
and so he appreciates that uh he's
trying to clearly appeal to both sides
levers and remainers and once again I
ask you is that possible it is possible
this country needs to move forwards we
found multiple ways to divide ourselves
from each other over the last few years
whether it's arguments about
independence in Scotland and growing
nationalism across England whether it's
the brexit divisions that we've been
scarred by for so long but actually when
we come together we build a country that
works and I think the the prevailing
mood of the times is that people want
this country to move forward we want to
start to rebuild our Public Services get
staff back into the National Health
Service get are buses and our on rail
networks working again and get people a
decent pay rise and all of these things
are only possible if we take a long-term
approach we make promises that we know
that we can deliver and don't make
promises that we can't and we involve
all people in all parts of Britain in
helping to rebuild our country
I'd like to ask you about these strikes
at the moment it's being called the Tory
party's winter of discontent which is
you know planning to present some laws
that ban strikes do you support striking
action I absolutely support the right to
strike but I desperately wish this
wasn't happening and so do the nurses
the postal workers the um the paramedics
all of the people at this country at the
moment that are struggling to keep their
Public Services going we need the
government to sit down and get round the
table and start to treat our Frontline
workers as partners in our national
Endeavor not as enemies and these laws
that the government are proposing are
the last Act of an absolutely desperate
government who understand the price of
everything but the value of nothing our
Frontline workers are going to help us
build our way out of this crisis and the
government needs to sit down with them
treat them as partners and work out a
plan
okay Lisa and Andy Shadow leveling up
secretary for housing and communities as
well thanks very much indeed thank you